yeah well I'm more of a doer than I'm a
dreamer I don't really dream I mean I do
I've written all this stuff up all one
day I'm on a jet and I'm gonna have a
bunch of Apartments but I wasn't
dreaming very big my apartment Target
was like a thousand units I thought if I
ever had 1 000 units that I would be in
the Pinnacle we owned 12 000 and I'll
probably buy that many this year but all
this has happened because of doing I
remember walked in a room and it was
empty and there was Chairs set up for
like 200 people I said one day I'm going
to speak to a full room with 200 people
sitting in the room well we've done 35
000 person events I never dreamed as big
as I've accomplished but I do like I'm a
doer there's no work that I won't do and
because I know I'll take out the trash
or pick up the boards or help the guy
out or whatever it is right because I
know I can do those things I could I
could do the bigger things too hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them because I don't
always wake up and feel motivated to go
take on the day and the thing that saves
me that helps me every day is being
around people who are thinking bigger
who are changing the world and it gives
me a little more inspiration to go after
my mission and so I hope this video
helps you go up to yours today too so
today let's get some incred Federal
motivation for the one and only Grant
Cardone enjoy
when to buy something stupid because
there's going to come a time in life
Jay-Z just bought a 200 million dollar
house dude he can do whatever he wants
to do he's worth two and a half billion
dollars okay I don't know that it was
the smartest thing to do but he can't do
it when do you do something stupid you
just got a contract for uh for 50
million dollars as an athlete when do
you do something stupid it ain't now I
guarantee you just because you got a
score doesn't mean you should go spin
start buying houses and cars and
okay this is when you should do
something stupid okay how stupid can you
go I'm gonna play a little song for you
here that my team created for you okay
number one number one number one
number one not that you will pay cash
but you need to be in a position to pay
cash for that thing if you cannot make
cash let's say I just got a contract for
12 million dollars as an athlete I got a
movie deal I got Advanced four million
dollars okay and they're gonna pay me
the other four million dollars when the
movie finishes I'm a sales guy and I
just got a big commission for 200 Grand
okay I I sold my company I picked up 10
million whatever you got a score okay
you would think oh I could do something
stupid right now you don't have your
cash yet so if you don't have your cash
yet you ain't gonna do it yet because
you ain't got cash if you can't pay for
it in cash don't do it doesn't mean you
will pay for it in cash it means you
have enough cash to do it number two you
need to have twice the amount of cash
or you need to buy two of them be able
to buy two of them not that you would
but this will give you the assurance
that you're not keeping things too tight
so let's say I find a watch I want to
buy Watch is 50 Grand I have to say I
could pay cash for the watch and I need
to be able to buy two of them
in order to say it's cool to do it that
will tell me that I'm Ready the third
thing the third filter here is this
money these number one and number two
cash and twice has to come from passive
income this is going to eliminate
probably 10
X okay the purchases that you make
because most people simply do not have
earn a passive income so if you're a
ball player and they said hey we're
gonna give you 50 million dollars you
don't start buying houses
my mama wants a house good can you buy
her two of them the house is two million
dollars
you got a 50 million dollar contract
that's earned income watch this my mama
wants a house that's two million dollars
okay can you buy two of them yeah you
can check check but here's the deal it's
not passive income you're not ready to
do this yet oh this is hard man why are
you showing me this grant why are you
waking me up to this because I'm trying
to tell you how to create wealth and
never be broke I want to share with you
the five benefits of real estate over
stocks and bonds number one and you
cannot deny this tangible asset real
estate is a physical very often very
difficult to replace asset it offers a
sense of security and the potential for
appreciation over long periods of time
unlike stocks pieces of paper and bonds
or even cash savings accounts or money
markets
real estate is a tangible asset as
opposed to intangible real estate
Investments give you the investor direct
control over a real asset number two
cash flows there is no asset gold silver
Bitcoin bonds or stocks that cash flow
like real estate real estate Investments
typically provide a consistent and even
monthly passive income for the passive
investor from rental income which offers
you a regular source of cash flow for
your investors and by the way cash flow
is what your family depends on okay
whether you're working or not you need
cash flow number three diversification
real estate Investments offer a great
diversification from traditional stocks
and bonds and potentially reduces
somebody's overall portfolio risk in
fact I'm so uh bullish on real estate
going forward that I actually have more
of my diversification across my asset
classes because of the number of doors
and different properties that I own in
different states that's right you can
actually take real State and had
diversification because of location and
scale number four inflation Hedge for
thousands of years real estate has
proved to be a great hedge against
inflation that we're in right now
meaning real estate generally maintains
or increases their value over time
beyond the cost of living Rises number
five in the Mack Daddy okay now I
wouldn't do this without the other four
but tax benefits or real estate are like
none other there is no comparison
anywhere in the world real estate offers
the best tax advantages deductions for
mortgage interest property taxes rehab
capex like it is endless including
accelerated depreciation which is
literally wiped out in many years my
income tax bill to zero look it's worth
noting that every investment as you know
has some kind of risk but if you want
the biscuit you got to risk it
and the best risk for me is to never
lose my money to get cash flow to get
appreciation to get leverage and to get
the tax write-offs enable one thing that
sounds like that and it's called real
estate get invested today as they say
don't wait and invest in real estate buy
real estate and wait if you over if you
overthink let's say I'm a thousand acts
right now yeah and you're not prepared
for that type of wealth or pressure or
experience or opportunity then is that
too big too fast no you should you
should still think bigger because you're
not going to know thinking smaller right
you're not going to know you're not
never going to get there
right I mean look the guy thinks too
small and he wins a billion dollar
lottery ticket
and he got lucky he's got problems too
he's just got new problems
he doesn't know what to do with the
money right so I if I would have thought
bigger
I I don't have the problem of not taking
action
okay so I'm not I'm not that guy I'm not
you got to deal with whatever you got
right but but I know this if I thought
smaller I would have taken fewer actions
when you start thinking really big you
you have to if you're going to go get
this thing if you're serious about
whatever that thing is
I didn't think I thought here because I
I thought I was thinking
oh yeah that's achievable
um
but how can I like how can a child a
three-year-old think that they can pick
up
um
100 pounds or ride a big horse
but they can't it's like not achievable
until Daddy picks him up puts him on it
and he's like oh I can run a horse you
know I can write it but but he when he's
looking up he's like I can't do that
yeah right so when you're looking for
you don't have anything you're just
hungry it's hard to dream man yeah
because because your stomach's saying
pay attention to me
or pay attention to my kids or shoes or
whatever whatever your your crunchy oh
inflation cost of bananas this is this
this is a fear cycle man this is like
like it it's then marketing fear to us
to stay small so we become consumers not
doers
consumers are worried about inflation
okay investors want inflation
producers want inflation
business owners want inflation okay if
you've got a career and you've got a
talent ball players want inflation if
you own a sports team you want inflation
if you own real estate you want
inflation but we're being told it's it's
bad why because they're treating you
they're messaging to you as a consumer
uh social media is bad for you it is bad
for a consumer it's not bad for a
Creator all right see what I'm saying so
I'm trying to get on the the cause Point
The Source Point of like okay I should
have been thinking about how do I build
a 50 million dollar business 15 years
ago a 100 really 100 billion
okay what would you have done
differently I would have studied 100
billion dollar businesses who did that I
should have been studying Jamie Diamond
this whole time I should have been
studying warrant what did they do not
what do they say
in their book interviews
because I've I've seen these guys on
panels and then I've had dinner with
right and bro it's two different
conversations they speak differently oh
yeah
well one one's for the ones for the gram
you know
once for the audience
for the for the clip
and the other is like hey let's go let's
go carve this deal up
this is how we make money in here how
big could this get they're always
talking about how big can you scale this
thing
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special
sheet just for this video the worksheet
will highlight all the Lessons Learned
in this video as well as pull out our
three favorite learnings and quotes that
will inspire you to actually do
something the worksheet will also give
you space to write down what your key
takeaways are and your specific plan of
action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there if
you want to stay in the middle class you
know good if that's your goal in life to
be in the middle of anything I'm not
peanut butter
I don't really want to be I've already I
grew up in the middle the middle middle
of a crowd does not seem like conducive
to my survivability I don't want my kids
to be middle kids I don't want I want to
be man I want to I want to take my
family to the top
so if you want to be in the middle pay
your debt off you want to get to the top
learn to use debt yeah because because
you know in all you know and I think
Dave would be open to this conversation
I know I would be I'm open to being
wrong Goldman Sachs in more about debt
JP Morgan's not worried about debt Elon
Musk is not worried about debt
they have debt they use debt Apple
computer has debt Apple computer has 200
billion dollars in cash and they borrow
money today why is that because they
want to use they want their cash
Reserves
on their balance sheet knowing debt is
not that debt is not the devil okay bad
debt using debt to buy a Gucci belt well
that's just stupidity you know but using
debt to buy building
that there that provides me with income
not a house by the way I own two homes
buying homes are bad deals yeah but
buying a home is a terrible deal yeah
putting debt on a home is even stupider
than buying the house itself I own but I
own two houses like I'm not telling you
guys I don't do stupid stuff I got these
I don't know what these are don't these
these shoes are stupid no reason for
anybody to buy these shoes I don't even
know why I have them on my phone right
now they're not even that comfortable
they're probably 800 or 1200 bucks or
something stupid if you're on the come
up that's dumb can't write it off
they're too much money definitely don't
put a credit card on them
but on good debt it pays me okay like I
bought a house in Malibu I paid cash but
I'm still I still have the cost of that
money right that that's been 40 million
dollars there I could be earning five
percent
that's two million dollars a year in 10
years that two million times 10 years I
need to make 20 million on that house
just to break even on the cost of money
and the purchase that that's not
maintenance property taxes Furnishing
the house or fixing it saving money is
ridiculous
you guys shouldn't save your money you
should take your money like this is what
I the game I've been playing since I was
31 years old and nobody knew I was doing
it I was calling on you guys getting
money from you and you were funding all
my real estate
and that's why I was hustling so hard I
was doing 300 days a year I'd get five
grand from you four grand nine grand
three grand two grand on any given day
the price could have been anything you
know if I needed a real estate deal I'd
call you guys hey man buy some of my
you know well what is it this week
oh it's a g pod you know any anybody buy
a g-pod from me g-pod was basically
basically what a g-pod was it was uh
Apple came out with that little the
little tiny thing Nana Nano yeah the
Nano so I took all my videos put it on
the Nano and called it a g-pod this in
2010 man half of you guys were out of
business okay I said you got to get the
g-pod the new g-pod man all my videos
are on the g-pop right and so some of
you guys would buy it I'd take the nine
grand and I'd invest the entire nine
thousand in real estate all of it always
broke never had any money didn't have
fancy cars or Gucci or nothing it wasn't
traveling anytime I travel I'd come
travel to you I'd go up to Winnipeg in
Thanksgiving because we didn't have
Thanksgiving in Winnipeg
the Canadians don't do that there's I'd
go there pick up a bag come back buy
some American Real Estate and just
buried in a real estate and stay broke
all the time I want to know how can I
Shadow work someone like you if I would
need a pitch you join The Mastermind why
haven't you done that honestly yeah
honestly yeah why haven't you it's not
me you down so what is it
[Music]
um you guys understand that any of you
that have not signed up for that it's
not me you doubt
like you can you can you can try to make
it about me but it's not me it's you
okay you guys doubt you you guys doubt
yourselves you understand you were so
far ahead of where I was when I was 21
years old I was 21 years old I was
getting pistol whipped
I was eating tranquilizers amphetamines
and had my face on a mirror all day long
like I was a wreck I was a disgrace to
my family and to myself
okay she's 21.
but you got you guys can learn the hard
way you can learn the fast way so I can
learn by Theory I need to actually feel
when I'm looking at you in this event
yeah I see promoting come to work for me
you want to come work if you don't want
to join The Mastermind you guys come to
work for me
come work for me every day Shadow me
I hate something move across the country
like how else you want to do it I can't
you want to hang out with me every day
oh
figure out what that is the way to do it
the way to do it is to study people okay
if you guys want to learn the game you
got to study someone
and you got to go deep on one person you
can't just like look at everything that
comes your way you got to study just
like you have interior design number
three rule know exactly what your cost
of living is it is shocking to me how
many people absolutely have no idea how
much income they make how much their
taxes are how much their house payment
their car payment they're electric their
water their utilities what they're
spending on their kids eating out
Chipotles ubering like you don't know if
you don't know you can't control what
you're doing okay so the first thing you
do is got to know exactly where every
single penny is going what are your kids
getting what is your wife spending what
are you spending what does gas cost you
oil costs you tires cost you count it
all if you simply take the last 90 days
and look through your checkbook and your
credit cards and you just total all that
up that is your cost of living okay take
that divide by three and that's what
it's costing you to live every month you
need to know that down to a nickel no
exactly what your cost of living is so
that you can start one controlling that
and number two outgrow that you got to
show up number one rule of success show
up
and uh see Rambo he showed up okay
Corleone showed up
Rambo showed up okay Armageddon Bruce
Willis showed up man I'd like to get him
for the 10x growth conference Die Hard
boys showed up
and of course oh my God Burt Reynolds
Arnold Schwarzenegger these guys showed
up you got to show up folks
show up okay now let me just show you
some things I'll show up and show off
okay this was given to me
thought leadership Forward Thinking
strategy for the 10th Annual 10th 10x
Global family office investment summary
in Dubai I showed up I spoke they gave
me this beautiful gift
okay
you show up man how you show up
most people don't show up most people
don't show up showing up it don't mean
you got to the office
you understand it doesn't mean you came
to work
for me showing up means I show up I've
been showing up since I was 25 years old
man before that I wasn't showing up
I was showing off
I was acting a fool being a fool
High School I didn't show up I went to
class I never showed up my body went in
the room
she's showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there and
then you showed up again and then you
showed up again and you showed up again
I mean she showed up for the class
she'll show up for the homework you show
up for the class you show up for the
homework you show up for the test you
freaking get a perfect grade means you
keep showing up to the next level
and I hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up is not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
Johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way
showing up as 100 percent of success
that means you show up and then you show
up again and you show up again you keep
getting better at your game you can't
keep showing up as the old you
you got to show up as the new you I made
the mistake in my career Jared Jared
talked about this it was I got
I didn't get the engagement right first
I was always engaged I was I've been gay
I've been like I've been hungry the
whole time how many hungry in the room
I mean
I've been hungry the whole time I just
hadn't been hungry enough
I should have I should have been
thinking about how do I get thousands of
people working for me
how do I get millions of people knowing
me I didn't know that that's what I was
supposed to be doing I was too worried
about selling him one product so I could
get the money because I was brought up
and we didn't have anything
so for me just to get 200 bucks I was
just doing get 200 bucks over and over
and over again I never thought about
scaling and saying hey how could I get
millions of people to go get 200 bucks
and I get a little piece of it I didn't
I didn't understand the scale I didn't
understand 10x 10x was written for me it
wasn't written for you
to next just solve some of my problems
okay I've been in business 30 years it's
only the last seven that changed my life
it wasn't the first 23. that's not
uncommon by the way
okay how old is Amazon
25 years old you would think they're six
or seven years old
okay when I heard they were 25 years old
I'm like I cannot believe that that
means that guy grinded that thing out
for 18 years
and the engagement if you're going to
scale you're gonna you're gonna get
frustrated
can't find the good people
come here they don't really want to work
here how many how many how many of you
in the room respond to resumes
people sent you a resume I want to work
for you you call them back they're like
who are you
right
their problem is your problem everybody
agree their problems are an extension of
your problems
if they can't make this if you can't
make the sale they're not going to be
able to make the sale if you don't
understand advertising and marketing
they're not going to be able to do it
correctly if you don't understand the
accounting department they how can they
possibly understand the accounting
department
I just always believe this I can do
something about this
I can do something about this situation
there's something I can do to solve this
problem this is a cycle of a business
I'm going to take one little idea and
I'm gonna turn it into a business eighty
thousand dollars a year to go to
Stanford Harvard MIT or Yale and never
learn this process this is a true story
I'm gonna write the millionaire booklet
watch what I do I'm driving home from
downtown Miami it was a charity event
and I gave some money to help this
charity that night and I'm driving home
and Elena's like I'm so proud of you
grant you did such a good thing tonight
I get home and I'm like I'm gonna write
a book tonight how to become a
millionaire most of you would sit down
and start writing the book what I did
next was write an offer
I'm like okay this book is going to be
uh 1995.
I'm going to sell it for 9.95 it's going
to be a pre-order I'm going to recalling
Sherry at midnight hey give me a give me
a landing site right now we're going to
call it the millionaire book and
Sherry's like you can't write a book
you're under contract with penguin
random right now and and they get your
next book I said did we agree to a book
or a booklet she's like a book book I
said good don't call it the millionaire
book call it the millionaire booklet
okay if that don't work we'll call it
the millionaire pamphlet okay let them
sue me later in the mind the mind says
oh I gotta write a book and you want to
think you need to finish a product I
don't think I need to finish a product I
need to start selling books okay now I
need to Market this book well Grant the
book's not finished right now okay ain't
nobody coming to your house at 12 30 at
night to get the book I start
advertising money I got a book so you
guys won't do that
you're like but I don't have a book I
got a book I got time nobody expects to
get the book in an instant I had a
landing page up see this landing page we
added the video the next day so idea
offer Market notice I haven't written
anything now I'm gonna sell it I'm gonna
close the fifth step will be to deliver
a service so what am I going to do here
right here you gotta write your book
okay I had this idea at 11 o'clock at
night at 11 20 I think we got our first
order 20 minutes after it and then I go
online and say hey guys if you could
help me translate my new book into
Arabic Hebrew can you please do this for
me and I'll give you credit for the
translation 38 languages in 30 days and
I paid a whopping zero more importantly
I got the word out on this new book now
I gotta write the book by one o'clock in
the morning 1am the book was finished
now you're like man how do you write a
book so fast because I was selling books
fast honesty integrity and ethics they
have power I commit to People by accept
their money the moment people start
giving me money I'm like oh I gotta
deliver now if you're a good person you
should have good things coming your way
if you don't have good things coming
your way and you're a good person that's
because something in your business cycle
is broken how can I own real estate
control real estate use the cash I have
in the bank to buy a piece of real
estate and have enough tenants pay me a
check every month
I didn't do it the way my uncle did it
my uncle did it one house at a time I
did it 100 units at a time my first deal
was 38 units my second deal was 48 units
my third deal was 90 units now we don't
even look at deals outside we we that
size we look at deals 400 units 500
units now why am I telling you this and
what should you take away from this
okay my first real estate deal was one
house I bought one house
I rented it and as soon as they moved
out I had problems I had to sell the
house just like my mom had to sell the
house so the first thing I want you to
know is this not all real estate makes
you money this piece of real estate
right here this guy paid 19 million
maybe 20 million bucks to build this
house he's going to sell it for 16
million dollars okay I come here I abuse
the damn place for two or three weeks
pay the guy 150 or 300 grand for two
weeks or three weeks that we stay here
and I walk away okay he gets income from
one person or eight people a year eight
people nine people maybe 10 people a
year maybe 12 people maybe he rents it
every week
but he won't do that every year because
if it doesn't snow he won't run it
don't buy single family homes when
somebody's not in it you got to make the
paycheck you got to pay the check okay
when I rent when I buy a hundred units
or 40 units or 30 units okay my first
deal was 38 units I never had less than
34 of those 38 units rented never did I
have less than 34 out of the 38 units
rented which was enough money to pay the
pay the the the note at the bank to pay
for the roof to be fixed to pay the
paint the tenants termites the toilets
the classified ads the problems some my
mama told me one day she's like you
don't want to get in real estate people
going to be calling you at midnight I'm
like I wish somebody would call me I've
been busting my ass my whole damn life
so somebody would call me God damn if
somebody would call me that means
they're paying me or they want to pay me
so what you gonna do
see your parents have half of everything
right
if they're millionaires they got half of
the equation right they got just enough
money now to say hey I made a bunch of
money I took care of my kids I got them
a college degree we got a nice house and
if I get a divorce it's going to cost me
half that's all the millionaires
nobody tells you that though nobody
tells you that look if you want to make
if you want real Freedom that's what my
dad wanted to provide my mom real
freedom and he never got there because
the week after my dad died my mom had to
sell that house that is not freedom
there was no debt on the house
except for the death the government puts
on every piece of property in America
property taxes okay and if you can't pay
the property taxes if you can't pay for
the Landscaping if you can't pay to have
the lawn mowed the snow to be picked up
and moved okay the pain to be fixed the
cedar the cedar Shake that's going to
fall off this place the roof that's
going to get damaged over some period of
time
if you can't fix all that it's coming
out of your pocket you're going to be
worried when you go to sleep at night
that's why I buy apartments and Office
Buildings because they provide income
from multiple tenants at one piece of
property it could be a hundred units 200
units 500 units the bigger the bigger
the more units the more protection you
get okay listen to what I'm telling you
that's one unit big nice big ass badass
house right beautiful
okay I'm gonna give them 200 Grand 300
Grand
I'm gonna walk away from this place
okay that one section of the roof over
there could cost him 300 Grand one year
and it will by the way that roof will
not last forever it's got 25 year life
he's got Plumbing issues here he's got
electrical Heating in the floors okay
you know the bridge is going to be a
problem we got water fountains swimming
pools that swimming pool's been at 106
degrees since I got here I'm like Crank
that bad boy all the way up who do you
think's paying the utility bill here not
me
so look not all real estate makes you
money the real estate that makes you
money is the real estate that produces
income every month positive cash flow
cash flow is the Holy Grail
the Holy Grail of all Finance is cash
flow a lot of people watch our videos
they aspire to assets properties Yachts
like this and they should what would be
some of the advice that you would give
them what I would recommend to people is
like number one lock-in that success is
important and finances are vital like
you need money and you need a lot of
money number one you need whatever you
think about money you're wrong
and and I'm telling you you're wrong
because you ain't never had any money
or been around anybody with any money so
you can't you shouldn't be making any
decisions about money it's crazy to me
how many people make decisions about
money and never had any and never had
anybody around them that had any money
so most of the people that say money
won't make you happy and it won't do
this and it won't do that I'm like you
don't know anything about money you
should you should just have a clean
slate and say I don't know anything
about money so money's important number
two uh don't lose money you need to
invest in it's guaranteed to make you
money once you earn it man take it and
use it for something that will make you
more money don't keep it don't save it
don't Ira it don't 401K it don't go buy
Gucci and crime shoes don't do any of
that in the beginning okay yeah
no no it's a terrible
you need you need you need in the
beginning right you need money you need
you don't want to save even three months
of money I would not save that old
about say for a rainy day you
need a 90-day Reserve I wouldn't do any
of that if I was starting over today
I would go out and earn money I would
take all the money invest in something
that paid me a little drip and I'd go
out and earn some more money throw it in
another deal pays me a drip I'm not
talking about stocks I want to convert
paper to an asset that's worth more than
paper as a cash flow and and so most of
these companies I mean we we're going to
look at a third of the companies on the
entire Stock Exchange or zombie
companies that will never produce income
ever and to work billions of dollars
they're garbage and they're going to go
into the dumper and a lot of people are
going to lose a lot of money gambling on
this so that's what I'll tell
you man money's important number two
don't lose it once you get it use it
you'll lose it if you don't use it
saving money is is a is a crazy stupid
game you'll never get wealthy doing that
and the third thing is surround yourself
with great people that are actually
moving towards these same things that
are interested in money and wealth
buying real estate is really a sales job
it's not really a buyer's job
so in the beginning when I was buying
real estate I had everything backwards I
thought I needed the money then I
thought I needed the debt I didn't know
anything about either one of them
and then I put the deal third today
we've just switched it hey man it's the
deal the deal the right deal will always
bring in the right debt there'll be
somebody to be like I'll be the debt on
that deal and the bigger these deals by
the way the bigger the deals the easier
the deals get like the debt you're the
easier the deck everything gets easier
like a 10 000 units would be easier for
me to purchase than one thousand a Reit
would be even easier for me to buy
we've had those phone calls this week it
would be easier for me to buy a Reit
even though I don't know where to get 10
billion dollars or 5 billion it would be
easier for me to buy a Reit than it
would be for me to buy a portfolio
so none of us are told this
unfortunately because uh maybe there's
an agenda to keep people small so it's
the deal it's the debt once you have the
deal and the debt together do the equity
not not even a problem there's no
shortage of money that will follow a
great deal so this is the last point
because you said this on a show now as
far as a Salesman not a buyer you got to
learn how to pitch you got to learn how
to talk to people you got to learn how
to pull people in you've got to learn
how to get attention and I don't mean
salesman in a bad way more probably a
better is a promoter to learn how to
promote and raise money in the beginning
if you just go back to February March
this year
I would tell my whole team I said guys
we're getting ready to go into one of
the hardest deepest ugliest nastiest
recessions I've ever experienced in my
60 years
and everybody's like oh my God here he
goes you know I'm like I'm telling you
I'm not and I'm not a silver gold
bitcoin's gonna go away world's going to
end the world never ends yeah this is
the most painful thing you know that
I've learned
in four recessions is that you always
survive them
but but that's the bad news you know you
you'll get through it you will get
through it you but most people
unfortunately are going to be a
statistic because of it
uh and and the big problem is most
people move too slowly to accept what's
going on
so in the beginning they lied to us
they've redefined the word recession
they also do that one vaccine
uh they're going to redefine what the
economy is by the time they've redefined
unemployment numbers those are probably
at 10 today they report three uh they're
lying about inflation today we're
already past the inflation bubble
problem we're probably in deflation now
not inflation
and uh the issue is not if they're gonna
lie if they've lied just as how many
times did they lied to you and the way
to find that out
is to Simply ask yourself is your family
doing better or not
64 of all small businesses in America
there's 32 million of them Break Even or
lose money
uh 70 70 somewhere between 68 and 76
percent of all Americans
uh live paycheck to paycheck and half of
all people that make a hundred grand a
year in this country live paycheck to
paycheck
so those things tell me you cannot have
330 million people in an educated
developed Nation where information is
available to everyone
you can't have that many stupid people
in one place okay that means that means
to me they're not Americans are not lazy
Americans are not stupid we're not you
know we haven't we have data do most of
us have computers and phones so why are
so many people suffering it's because we
have been
doctrinated
to benefit Wall Street and the banks
and it's time that people say okay and
it's happening right now people are
starting to wake up social media is
actually waking the world up I think
what's going on in the last three or
four years since covid and the election
co-bid ascendant 200 billion dollars to
Ukraine like people are starting to wake
up and say wait a minute something's
going on and I don't know if it's in my
best interest
so we're going to go into a very
difficult recession we're in one already
they'll tell us later that we were and
businesses are going to go out of
business uh
households are going to find out that
they they don't have the money they
don't have enough savings they don't
have enough Investments they're going to
find out their cash is worthless they're
going to have to struggle this year in
2023 with with even maintaining their
business or growing it but
they're Silver Lining here okay Silver
Lining is
during recessions is when people can
actually grow if they have the
strategies because there's fewer people
to to participate and compete with
so there's the bad news man the good
news is I'm going to grow there's three
great pivots I've had in my career and
they all came on the tail of a recession
Warren Buffett recently said the reason
they don't buy real estate is because
real estate for most most of the of time
for hundreds of years in America real
estate is properly valued and he looks
for assets that are not properly valued
or something they're stressed they're a
problematic and he says the reason real
estate they have not been able to
accumulate real estate uh at Berkshire
is because there's only one thing that
causes real estate to be incorrectly
valuated or valued and that one thing is
financial problems crisis a crisis a
debt crisis or banking crisis it
happened in 1996 that's when I started
buying real estate it happened again in
2008 I bought a bunch of real estate and
it's going to happen right now so we
have a correction that is completely
underway and it's happening right now
two the second reason you want to be in
real estate is because it's time tested
okay it's been around for thousands and
thousands of years real estate is is
valuable or more valuable than gold the
reason I like real estate more than gold
or silver or hard products or
Commodities is because it provides me
with cash flow not just a a real product
okay three it builds net worth
you know this about your home your
personal home can build net worth okay
your your parents bought a house for
twenty eight thousand dollars thirty
years ago house is worth four or five
hundred grand a day and it's paid for
that Bill's net worth number four major
reason major reason that you want to do
this is the tax benefits okay most of
you don't understand the tax benefits
taxes represent 40 percent of all your
expenses at least
some of you guys that live in
Connecticut New York New Jersey Illinois
California dude your tax bill is in the
60 percent you don't even know it
unemployed employment taxes Social
Security benefits uh property taxes
sales taxes car taxes
um
okay number five passive income okay
passive income now Bitcoin does not
offer passive income stocks do not offer
passive income uh five-year treasury
bills don't offer passive income cash at
the bank doesn't offer passive income
work does not offer a passive income you
need passive income Warren Buffett said
if you don't learn how to make money
while you sleep you will spend your
entire life working for money you can't
keep
did y'all know the whole the whole
saying right there that's what it is
number six okay number six inflation
hedge
and we about to go through some people
believe that we're going to go into
hyperinflation in this country because
we keep printing money it's probably
it's probably five to ten years from now
but if we go into hyperinflation if
you've ever lived in countries like
Venezuela Argentina go to Greece look at
what happened in Greece 15 years ago
Dude they were literally burning their
money in the streets okay they were
literally using it for firewood you guys
that are just getting started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
the first thing I had to do to get my
life moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm gonna beat that son up every morning
so that I have the discipline and the
control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I have the same
weekends or for the week
I was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people making poor choices
at 25 years old I cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life that weren't committed to the
same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day kick start your day get going in
your day to give you a sense of respect
for yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that scent up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I
started building respect for myself
start believing in myself so that I can
go out into the world and maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when I go into
this meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
beat the Sun up never give up on your
financial goals until you achieve your
financial goals there's people in this
room folks that are going to be worth
billions of dollars
there's a billionaire in this room right
now I guarantee you could be two or
three up
billionaires in the making right here
okay questioning who's it going to be
now if somebody in this room how many
believe this is somebody in this room
made a decision I'm going to put
together a billion dollars how many
believe that's possible
everybody in the room believes it's
possible you might not think it's
possible for you but you know it's
possible which means what the money's
available
would you would you do good things with
that billion dollars
okay you know that about yourself you
don't know about the guy sitting next to
you
you know that about yourself
so you know somebody could do it and you
know if you did it you do good things
with it right
so go do it man because the money's out
there there's plenty and I grew up with
a little uh five uh four foot 11 uh
Italian lady that knew nothing about
money she just knew hold on clip coupons
save your money how many were brought up
like that Penny saved is
Penny earned
say for a so you were brought up the
same way I was eat all your
eat all your food if you don't eat it
all save it put it in the refrigerator
right some of you got you got food in
your refrigerator right now three and
four five days old
you have you have no intention of eating
it
some of you got you got like an eighth
of a bagel left from five days ago
right now you're like it's in there
right now you got you got you got ice
cream in your in your freezer that's
like six months old
it's expired twice
it's got that much frost on it but you
got one bite left
I know it's still good you tell your
kids this too you pass on the same
to your kids eat all your food
eat all your food eat all your food and
then you wonder why we got obesity
problems in America
we live in a country that's rich and the
people have scarcity in their minds
what's your thoughts and feelings around
what is happening and what you think
will happen over the next 12 days right
so I'm going to say something that I
think most people will disagree with me
on but first of all inflation is is a
boogeyman that's not even real really
look I'm just telling you inflation even
Warren Buffett says maybe two people on
the entire planet even understand the
concept of inflation what is so
complicated what is inflation so
inflation yeah it's a great question
right and what is a recession by the way
yeah so uh inflation is uh an increased
price or price on some commodity that is
desired right so you actually want
inflation
you don't not want inflation why because
you want your value you want your the
value of your products to go up not down
if you're thinking as a consumer okay
which you're not dreaming big if you're
thinking as a consumer oh my God bananas
went up okay don't eat them
uh eggs went up eggs did not go up
because of the the this Boogeyman
okay and it didn't go up because the
dollar went down in value
so if I and it didn't go up because we
print money it's none of this is true
you know I know your audience in the
comments they're going to freaking just
try to destroy him so if we print a
bunch of money if you print a trillion
dollars okay and put it in this building
right now
nothing inflated
you just printed a bunch of money it is
the distribution of that money
okay I distribute the money to a billion
people
then they have money okay that even the
distribution of the money sharing a
trillion dollars would not increase
inflation it is when in it is when the
money is moved into the marketplace
that's when inflation happens if the
consumer the dreamer the person
elects to use the money okay so
inflation was created because we gave
everybody a fourteen hundred dollar
check
and people went and bought they didn't
need and couldn't afford by the way
inflation is created by me buying eggs
that are too expensive that I can't
afford
so if the eggs are too expensive don't
buy them the marketplace will take care
of it then it'll go back down exactly
okay so your supplies will go up and
people will be like I got all these eggs
I want to get rid of them so listen I'll
do two for one oh three for one or four
for one the inflation was caused by the
supply chains blocked up because of
covet and because things weren't getting
shipped around the country it was not
caused because inflation is not caused
because of printing money even though
that's what most people believe
causes inflation if I print
a trillion dollars and leave it in this
room it would be filled up more than
this room but if I printed a trillion
dollars or four trillion or Six Trillion
whatever they just just did and leave it
in this room there's no inflation it's a
non-event so this idea that printing
money increa creates inflation is not
the truth now if I distribute six
trillion dollars
to every household in America I still
have not actually
caused inflation okay because it hasn't
been used it's not in the system yet you
get a bunch of money she gets a bunch of
money my daughter gets a bunch of money
I get a bunch of money until we move the
money into the marketplace
now if all these people went out and
bought assets real assets yeah of course
every I'm we're all able to pay more
money because we have more money so if
you just if your audience can just
follow the thinking here and I'm just
asking people to think of think with
this sure because this is what I'm
thinking with the reason we have
inflation is because people were sent
fourteen hundred dollar checks some of
your audience is not gonna like what I'm
about to say say it
you guys were sent a fourteen hundred
dollar check you got a fourteen hundred
dollar check and you went and spent
money that you shouldn't have spent on
you didn't need
that is the new definition of inflation
people that get money and then spending
on stuff they don't need don't really
don't don't they're not required living
and you probably couldn't afford and
wouldn't done it had you not gotten that
check now people like me I I didn't I
didn't cause inflation you caused
inflation
I went and took my money and invested it
I buried it in projects in real assets
and so every time I got any check over
the last two or three years or for the
last 30 years I take all the money I get
it's all garbage money's garbage and I
convert it into buildings I'm walking
through you what is what is your
assistance name uh Alex Johnson yeah
you're awesome bringing me into the
building what was I saying all the way
from the curb oh my God this building I
should buy this building like I just get
like to me buildings are like like
they're like I I I can buy this today if
I can hold on for for 10 or 15 or 20
years what would you say your superpower
is
I mean you've done all kinds of things
and you've got an incredible track
record but what would you say like your
superpower is right now as you sit here
today
everybody's got a lot of superpowers so
what's the dominant one that you would
say Grant Cardone when you look in the
mirror it's like this is what I do this
is my special sauce one is persistence
man I just don't quit like if I tell you
guys I'm gonna buy a hundred thousand
units and I am going to own 100 I'll be
the one of the largest apartment owners
in the world I have never ever stopped
the only way to stop me is to kill me
and then I'm not I'm I I would even
question whether I come back or not my
boom you know so so persistence I I have
built my persistence muscle up it was
all that cold calling I was doing when I
was 30. uh the second one is I'm
extremely disciplined with money and it
doesn't matter whose it is
it could be your money your brother's
money
it doesn't matter whose it is I watch
money I never lose it I respect it and I
try to multiply it
um and on the same thing on buying
property like I don't use your money any
different than I would my own money I'm
not Reckless
um because I'm self-made like I'm I came
up from the mud and you know I've never
had a silver spoon I've never had
anybody give me anything the fact that
I've never taken money for an
institution and and got the size that I
am is like it's really unheard of this
is what you never want to do and I've
said for years never never ever
over leverage your properties these guys
were born 80 and 85 and 90 sometimes a
hundred percent of the deal they were
putting basically 20 down that was
raised money check out what they were
doing there they got interest rate a
floating interest rate that's now at
seven and a half and they promised their
investors some preferred interest uh
probably eight to twelve percent I don't
know exactly what they offered in this
deal but each deal had to basically make
20 a year
just to break even and they hadn't even
done the rehab yet so they had to pay
back 20 a year plus they had to spend 15
20 or 20 000 a unit on thousands of
units 20 million dollars
on a bad location
okay so they bought product location
over leveraged it
and then they had no cash reserves in
case of problems like there's not going
to be problems guys there's always going
to be problems okay every piece of real
estate I've ever bought every business
I've ever purchased every business that
I started every startup I've got
involved in every relationship
partnership every single deal I have
ever bought came with problems that I
did not forecast I did not manage most
of you guys who are buying real estate
in the last three years you're like oh
we're going to have growth every year
we're going to have a rent growth
forever everything's gonna go perfect
we're going to do our rehab we're going
to keep it full at 95 percent why does
everybody use this 95 number not it's
impossible not not everybody can be at
95 percent okay particularly with they
got new assets coming on these guys were
buying Assets in terrible locations
knowing that new product was coming on
in an adjustable rate mortgage Market
where the FED said the interest rates
are going to be going up we're under
capitalized don't have money for the
future to buy down the loan and check it
out didn't even have any reserves to fix
the property we're an America man yeah
there's another guy named Warren Buffett
that's worth 90 billion
a little older been around the game a
little longer and you know if you listen
to him he's gonna be like this game will
not end not this this country will not
end okay there's 330 million people here
the entire planet depends on America
we're consumer Nation we consume
everything we consume everybody's good
products and good is the best interest
of every plant every country on planet
Earth including our enemies
which you know that we're told they're
our enemies but behind the scenes we're
probably buddy buddy with them oh yeah I
don't think this game ends okay and even
if it does then a friend of mine he had
just uh sold his company walked away
with four billion dollars he's like
Grant just remember
this planet is like Monopoly the game
only ends when the players walk away
he said no matter how bad things get man
eight billion people uh there's always
going to be 5 billion of them working
5.4 billion 90 of them are going to be
grinding out every day buying clothes
buying food buying water you just got to
decide if you want to play with play
with those people if I reach enough
people on this planet and you can today
with social platforms everything from
Instagram to Facebook to Snapchat to
Twitter's audio spaces uh clubhouses
stages
um Billboards and media if you if you're
creative enough money will never be a
problem big shout out call the haters
and the criticizers
the rumor mongers the gossipers
the people out there that uh that here
on the clubhouse Instagram or Facebook
hating on people criticizing people
making people wrong bullying them just
remember this when you hear that when
you hear somebody hating on somebody
else
in my 63 years of being on this planet I
have never in my life had somebody hate
on me and I've had a lot of people hate
on me criticize me
try to shame me
pick out all my damn Character defects
look at all the iron in here okay you
got something really special back here I
have never ever
had somebody hate on my game that
accomplished more than I had
it's not one damn time in my life
Elon those guys over at the top of the
food chain they're not talking about me
threatened by me
I've had some people
unable
to accomplish what I've accomplished
it's been all their damn time talking
about me
you know the crazy thing is when you're
talking about somebody that's above you
just accomplished more than you trash
throwing up at people above you and
always on the phone with your face
everybody listening to it saying okay
yeah oh that's funny that's funny that's
funny and then they're gonna be like why
is he talking so much
education
forehead your reputation
so look for all of you out there just
remember when you're hearing somebody
hate on somebody else that person I
guarantee you there you'll never find
there to be an exception to this rule
person they're hating on is accomplished
more than they have
the person is doing it is accomplished
not nearly
a fat man
look Envy really Envy is the core it's
the core of the root of hate
Envy jealousy
insecurities scarcity
trying to trying to tear somebody else
down
to build themselves up and it never
works you just can't do that you can't
get up tearing other people down oh you
end up and downs like their crab
syndrome in the bucket
pulling each other down trying to get up
and they just keep pulling each other
down so
remember when you hear somebody hating
on whatever a person or a company
religion
family fun
a movement when you are being bullied
or
somebody's attempting to bully you tear
you down
ruin your reputation you were talking to
somebody that is filled with jealousy
and envy and insecurities and scarcity
complexes and narcissism and
[Music]
when they're hating they're not creating
when they're not creating they cannot do
better in life it's impossible it's like
a disease from the inside so just
remember that when you're hearing that
you might want to separate yourself from
those that are doing that you definitely
don't want to be that because those that
do that don't do much else if you have a
spending problem you know it so what I
want to share with you here is how to
never have a spinning problem okay
because if you earn 400 million dollars
boxing and you spend 401 million dollars
you're not going to have any money okay
and that has happened to many many ball
players Fighters uh actors you name it
they spend more money than they earn so
first thing we want to fix here is I
need to make more money okay if you make
enough money spending will never be your
problem but once you start making money
and you start doing stupid stuff which
is what people do by the way that's how
you get inflation inflation is created
by the government printing money you
take the fourteen hundred dollar check
and you go spend it on a a pair of
Gucci's that you can't write off that
you couldn't afford that you couldn't
buy two up you you put it on credit you
bought stupid stuff inflation is created
when people get money and go buy stupid
stuff with it that they didn't need here
we are 2023.
a home is 400 Grand it's going up 15
times and interest rates doubled in the
last couple years so the same you know
interest rates were 18 back then it but
it was still a lower payment than on on
25 000 than it would be today uh and a
lot of people are like I don't want to
own a home today it's not a great
investment but there's going to be so
many opportunities here real estate
there's a couple of vectors they're
going to offer phenomenal phenomenal
opportunities you mentioned some of the
stocks the the
most efficient stocks companies in the
world the apples the Facebooks that the
I don't know about the Netflix because
they're going to get pounded here but
yeah it's tough Coca-Cola is the
McDonald's these are companies that
deliver real products and real and maybe
don't even have to go outside the
country to get them like Dunkin Donuts
you know there's no there's no supply
issues there they they cook their donuts
in the morning and Brew their coffee and
sell it and make a margin
real estate is going to be tremendous
opportunity single-family homes and
Commercial Real Estate like I buy
tremendous phenomenal
uh Decades of opportunities like
literally I'll probably buy more real
estate this year than I bought in the
previous decade and I bought a lot of
real estate and then small businesses
there's 32 million small businesses that
I mentioned earlier uh about 18 million
of them Break Even or lose money those
people that own those businesses are
tired they went through covid now
they're going through inflation they're
exhausted they're they're over 50 years
old some of them over 70 years old and
they're like I'm tapping out I think
it's a it'll be easier this year to buy
10 businesses with no money
for your audience it doesn't have any
money you could literally buy 10
businesses today
cheaper than you could start your own
business and probably ex scale 10 times
faster than grow your own business 10 a
lot of you've been asking me about my my
workout regimen uh some of you may or
may not know but
two years ago I couldn't do a push-up
I wasn't in terrible shape but man my
body was starting to hurt
you know I'm 63 years old so
there's no way you can't you can hold on
to it without doing the work and when I
was a kid
I was for whatever reason my metabolism
uh genetics whatever I was never uh
as always I could just pick it up quick
physically fairly strong but you know
short sharp muscles and they would
respond really quickly
and then
I started believing I could get away
with that
and then you start hitting 40 45 and 50.
this is no way so what I what I did
today you just saw my money basically my
my routine I changed it up a little bit
I'm in my recovery room right now this
is a magnet I'll I'll post some of the
things that it does and
uh some of the benefits of it but
basically
you can do is finish my workout uh spent
eight minutes on this magnet
it's basically electronic magnet that
separates the cells in the body and gets
everything where it's supposed to be to
it's like oxygenating all my cells then
I'll go to the egg over here sauna
and by the way I any of you that want
any of these products let me know I
represent all of them
that is a hyper Pro it has a 30 minute
30-minute uh sauna it Heats to 194
degrees
Corona cannot live it runs in real
Corona cannot live it 140.
and that sauna to what a place to relax
man amazing
so I'll spend 30 minutes in that
[Music]
I'll spend 30 minutes in the sauna and
then I'll do 20 minutes into infrared
bed this is a Mack Daddy right here this
bed right here is 28 thousand dollars
just that here's I know if you can even
get one
that's a hundred and uh it's the best in
the world 80 000 lights invisible
lighting like it is fantastic for
immunity runs off of a pad over here so
I can pull up everything from
uh inflammation joint pain pain
recovery anti-aging sleep immunity
energy soft tissue recovery so these are
three things I do every day one thing I
was going to say Brian and granted as I
know coming up you talked earlier about
the recession Grant I know Brian our our
followers and audience are just Avid
about taking action that's one thing
that's great is and that's something you
teach probably Let's Take Action so
Grant you know maybe you guys both talk
a little bit about the upcoming um
challenge you're doing which I love one
of the topics is really how to thrive
during challenges in the recession some
of the things you're going to be
teaching because I think it's so
important everybody that's following you
Brian all of our subs they really need
to get involved in this because it's
some really good stuff but what I heard
Grant talking about this a few months
ago
like if you guys agree with my statement
about you know sometimes the truth is
not is a painful pill to take
and and as much as the truth might hurt
folks we are going we have 13 trillion
dollars worth of debt in this country
that was taken on in the last two years
oh wow
this is more this is more debt than than
his like we printed almost 80 percent of
all the US dollars in circulation yeah
happened in the last 36 months now
you're like okay well what what does
that mean it means you should have got a
pay raise
if you didn't get a pay raise you did
not get a part of the print
which means your hustle's off uh
inflation uh Warren Buffett says
inflation is it's it's a it's the most
misunderstood Concept in the world and
most people when they hear the word
inflation they get scared but the truth
is your assets should have gone up in
value
the things that you own should have gone
up in value if you have wealth already
you should embrace inflation
if you don't have wealth then you have
to be like okay I got to start getting
some assets because they benefit from
inflation yes and you don't need money
to buy assets but you do need a strategy
and you need a commitment a Target yeah
so like my little company this year last
year we did 145 million dollars in
internet sales and in 12 month period
wow like I don't even have an inventory
I don't have inventories like like I
built this out of recessions to become
Unbreakable
because I've been broke so many times
that I'm like I don't want to keep
getting going backwards you know like I
can't keep going back because I got to
figure out what there's something I
don't know and don't understand
so I had like I had 401 case IRAs I had
a house paid for I got rid of all that
in 2008 sold the house
converted the money out of the house and
my IRA accounts to start making
Investments
and and I quit playing by the house
rules Brian that you and I were brought
up on save your money 90-day reserves uh
buy house pay it off I'm like no I'm
investing all this money in me I've been
investing in our customers and I'm
invested in my expansion
and so I would just tell everybody right
here Eric based on your question you
guys need to reassess what's an asset
and what's a liability right now right
okay and and because the game is
changing radically in a way you have
time to you have time to re you gotta
really challenge everything you've been
told uh by Wall Street and by your
education and by your friends and family
yes
um because a house is not going to make
you money it's never going to make you
money houses are not built to make money
and saving money in a bank helps the
bank but it doesn't help you in saving
money in IRAs and 401 case helps Wall
Street but it doesn't help you notice
who's getting wealthier the banks in
Wall Street not individuals if you want
to get rich
if you're unselfish enough to secure
your money for yourself your family your
community and your household that's what
I'm talking about rich rich is I can
give to my church
and still give to my family rich is I
can go on a big trip and still give to
my church rich as I can take care of my
family and my church and still take care
of take care of strangers and invest in
projects maybe that I love riches hey I
got Prosperity an afternoon okay a
million dollars divide by 25 years is 4
000 a year is that right
forty thousand I'm sorry I missed a zero
doesn't really matter it's still no
money you can't live on forty thousand
bucks a year you can't send your kids to
decent schools you can't take care of
your mom the sick you can't take care of
one car wretch wreck much less a car
wreck and a little bit of cancer you
can't do anything and you can't give
anything to your charity why because you
didn't plan correctly if you want to
become a millionaire number one you have
to decide to become a multi-millionaire
you're going to miscalculate the zeros
and this is what the 10x rule was the
10x rule was a multiplier you must
multiply in order to add
you have to learn how to do something a
lot of times to ever get good at it what
did you do to get from 1 billion to 4.2
in three years I bought more real estate
I mean that's how you do it you got to
buy the real estate right you gotta you
know you gotta you gotta either raise
money or you got to have money and
both of those are possible so you guys
out there are saying I don't have any
money oh my God if I had money I'd have
done that too no you got to either get
money earn money or you got to raise
money one of the two
and it's easier to raise money if you've
already worked and earned money because
then people can trust you that you know
how to trade time for money at a job
so you know like people trust me they
trust my work ethic people may not like
my energy or
they might not like the way I say
something but nobody's going to say I
don't work they're going to say here's
guys got track record 35 years showing
up doing what he said he was going to do
yeah he's he's cocky and he's this and
he's that and and he says whatever he
wants but look you probably would too
like like yeah but but I do what I say
I'm going to do too and and and and then
I stack real estate assets we picked up
three billion dollars almost three
billion during the pandemic
and then took a Hiatus we hadn't bought
anything in the last year and we're I'm
about to I'm about to blow this
portfolio up so next time I'm on this
podcast I'll be at 10 billion this cycle
right now that we're in is going to be
the biggest real estate opportunity in
my lifetime
and everybody is listening like this is
it's it's time to be ready all the time
not get ready because it's happening
right now what's your advice to Brokers
headed into this season right because
most Brokers I know have had an epic run
the last two or three years epic run
made an insane amount of money right
they don't even know how to dial right
exactly they forgot how the fundamentals
right they forgot they stopped doing it
because it was so easy they got a
listing and had 20 offers so in this
current season we're going into Brokers
are down 70 80 they're forecasting being
down 70 80 in sales volumes what's the
advice for some of the top for the
Brokers out there you know you need to
go back and really
you know renew those relationships that
maybe you've ignored a little bit
um
I know what we're doing like you know
Brokers are very very valuable to us
like insane yeah never paid too much for
a broker they've never earned too much
money on a deal
um Brokers out there like you got to
find out who's buying I'm I'm on the top
I'm on the list now the problem with the
list today is the other guys on the list
are institutions
so you're going to have to go in the
list now and find the individuals
because the individuals are going to
reign
power for the next 18 months
I I got two meetings this week from the
top five groups to go look at their
portfolio to purchase I could not get
that meeting a year ago so I would tell
Brokers you guys need to arrange that
meeting for me individuals
entrepreneurial people with a bunch of
powder I'm sitting on 350 cash right now
350 big ones okay and I'm raising money
every day and I don't mind moving into
this cycle this I was built for this
cycle you got to find more guys like me
that did not depend on Sovereign funds
hedge funds and institutions for their
dough what are you going to do on a
daily basis you got to keep yourself
busy you got to figure out some kind of
way to keep yourself busy they're going
to share with you my team's going to
share with you a little schedule I use
I'll be talking about goal setting how
to set goals how to achieve goals how to
keep your calendar full because if your
calendar is not full and you said okay
I'm gonna quit doing dumb stuff and I'm
gonna I'm gonna quit hanging around
these idiots
um well the truth is you got nothing to
do and you're going to sit around and
boredom is going to get you and you're
going to go back and you're going to
start doing the same you were doing with
the same people you were doing it with
it wasn't until I filled up my calendar
with activities
and then got good at those activities
that my life actually changed and the
last thing was I had I needed to start
adding some people that could change my
life so the last three things is you got
to get better at something keep your
activities full when you're winning when
you're doing things you're good at you
will want to do it a lot you will not
burn out on things you're doing well and
the other thing is you've got to get
around the right people why do I insist
that apartments are the greatest
investment of the group why should you
focus here for your initial foray into
real estate investing in short it's
because Apartments passed a number of
tests that are vital to you not having
to worry about whether or not you're
going to make money in a deal okay
you're here to win you're here to make
money I'm all in on apartments for key
reasons first apartments or real assets
when you own apartments and you own real
tangible assets you benefit from a
number of things one you benefit from
appreciation going forward if you picked
a good location cash flow right now now
while you sit and wait and it's more
expensive in the future going forward to
build these apartments than it was to
buy them number two apartments produce
positive cash flow at least they should
if you bought it right if you got the
right debt on it and if you pick the
right property Apartments produce
positive cash flow which is the Holy
Grail of finance a concept that very few
people ever get right almost as
importantly as inflation same thing with
cash flow you're underestimating the
value of positive cash flow when you
pick a property it is cash flow that
gives it value going forward because one
you get to keep it long term and two it
gives you security when you go to sleep
at night now that brings me to number
three this is called the multiplier
effect when rents rise if they do in
your Market apartment values increase if
you're ready to take the next step and
start investing in real estate like a
total Pro you have to start with the big
why why a particular class of asset stay
broke stay broke y'all got to stay broke
man cash is garbage you don't need money
you don't need cash cash is trash your
mommy and daddy didn't know this cash is
garbage it is trash take it out use it
it is worthless until it is put to work
okay listen to me money is worthless
until it is put to work
money is useless until it is used
it's a piece of paper
okay it's got God on it look how they
treat this let's put God on there man
okay we'll put a we'll put Ben Franklin
it wasn't God's idea to have his his
name on a piece of paper everybody agree
with that that's that's a pitch
come on man put Ben Franklin on this
right he's a president
okay like he ain't he ain't my president
he did
and then we act like a sacred I got to
keep it and protect it and now it's mine
this is what this is what uh Brandon was
doing this morning we're talking about
currency if you look at the word it
comes from current current flows it has
to be in circulation
right it's it's it's plentiful it's a
piece of paper it's only valuable when I
take it out of my pocket get it out of
the system and put it to work
if I give it to the bank if I call up
Wells Fargo today and say Here's a
hundred dollars what are they gonna do
with it
they're going to convert it it instantly
converted into digits and then they will
send it out nine times
almost 10x what Roi are you looking when
you're investing okay Roi return on
investment okay or we would call Cash
Flow It's the cash flow that I'm really
looking for okay there's there's a
couple terms one is uh you could use Roi
cash flows the term all these are made
up though guys like it's like how good
is the building the better the building
is the better the future the building is
the less I need for return Why number
one reason you want to write this down
number one reason and you need to know
these you need to know this is why I'm
doing this
he's not sure why he's doing it because
right now he's like what's my Roi okay
number one reason it might be because of
your age but number one reason is what
preserve capital
why am I buying the real estate okay why
am I buying the real estate I want to
preserve Capital Melissa gave me a
million dollars I'm a consultant I
consult their business she gives me a
million dollars to consult the business
I want to preserve the million dollars
if you keep the million dollars you're
going to lose it you're going to get
taxed out of it it's going to depreciate
everybody agree you want to convert
paper to buildings
okay I like I have a rule I never
convert paper to more paper
I'll I'd convert it to bitcoin before I
converted back to dollars or treasury
bills personally
I actually believe in the blockchain
more than I believe in the treasury
Department
oh yeah this guy oh here go the Maxis
[Music]
Bitcoin people go crazy now watch okay
how many crypto people in the room
these people are nuts
okay they're like the drug addicts of
the blockchain
[Music]
okay you start talking to these people
you drop a quarter in them tell me about
crypto oh
these people were taught for 17 days
all right so one you want to protect
your capital okay this is why people get
it now I want to keep it the way to keep
it is to convert it you cannot keep cash
without losing it it's going down in
value in your lifetime it's lost 70
percent of its value my lifetime has
lost seventy percent of my value yeah
exactly okay one you want to protect
your Capital number one two you want
cash flows these are my criteria for
investing in anything that's why I don't
load up on bitcoin because it doesn't
hit number two it doesn't cash flow all
you have to do is go out and be willing
to go talk to people and if you go talk
to enough of the right people then you
will find the right person and and
literally that this was so funny because
he uh was telling me after he got back
he's like literally within the first uh
48 hours I had met the two people that
were going to make everything that
happened on that show possible I knew I
knew it wasn't it wasn't a week it
wasn't it wasn't a month it was
literally The First 48 hours all I did
for the first 10 days is meet people
okay but you got to meet the right
people okay who are the right people
you know who are assets and who are
liabilities okay on day one in 19 days
in this workbook we're going to take a
list of the people that you know okay
and the people you don't know that could
actually change the the the the future
of your life okay
who could actually change the future
make you the millionaire the DECA
millionaire
Hector millionaire the hector
millionaire or the billionaire because I
promise you you ain't getting there
without them
and the people that you know
have you where you are
just so you know like the people that
you know if your network is your net
worth
then the network you have right now has
something to do with the network that
you have right now you guys got to
become a threat to your environment you
got to become a threat to your
environment you got to become such a
threat to your environment people start
like your competition starts talking
about you because that's free promotion
you got to get people to promote you and
you can't nobody's going to promote
somebody not winning
you know they're not going to hate on
people losing they're going to hate on
people that are winning
it just comes with the thing so in in
that promotion because people don't
remember you remember uh Tylenol Tylenol
was taking off the shelves 20 years ago
number one best-selling headache
medication in the world today
and it was taken off the shelves
so so you have to figure out how to get
how to do something big enough in your
Marketplace you know the fourth reason
to Market is to get a customer but if
you hit the third one you're going to
get the fourth one
so I don't know if I answered your
question but you can't stay you can't
you can't just keep being a 50 car store
right so the 10x concept would be this
like okay we did 50. we're going to
figure out how to do 500. right you
don't go 50 to 55 because you're never
going to get to 55. cash is not
King
[Music]
cash is garbage okay cash flow now would
be a different conversation
constant cash flow kind of look cash is
going down in value in fact I want to
give you something I did a little study
this morning in in 1960
okay this is a conversation everybody
here if you want to know more about
money you have to figure this out okay
in 1960 if I had one thousand dollars
and then I come out to if I come out to
9 2018.
how much money how many thousands of
dollars do you think I would need in
1960 to buy the same services today
as in 1960. I was born in 1958 by the
way
8 000 in 1992 and 1992 this thousand
dollars and you take it out to to 2018
you would need you would need uh
[Music]
Seventeen hundred and forty four dollars
to buy the same goods and services okay
this was
82.69 so now this is really really
important don't get lost here you're
like what just happened here okay I'm
going to show you I'm going to give you
a very simple very very simple and I'm
going to explain to you what Warren
Buffett says only a handful of people on
planet Earth understand it's called
inflation there's a thousand dollars
and I'm just going to pull off what
looks like eight
yeah that's eight
I gotta add one it's short 100 okay I
wonder how close I am maybe somebody can
count this out okay okay now in 1960
when I was when I was two years old this
is what it took you could go with a
thousand dollars and you'd buy whatever
washing machine dryer car payments house
payments blah blah blah if you wanted to
buy those items today those same items
today this is the understanding of
inflation you would need eight times the
money to purchase the same products okay
so what happened okay ask yourself this
question a thousand dollars in 1960 is
worth what today
if I had a thousand dollars put it in my
drawer in 1960 came back 57 years later
58 years later and grabbed it how much
money would be in the drawer same
thousand dollars is in there nothing
happened to the thousand dollars you
understand we still have a thousand
dollars this is this is inflation
simplified
this is what they don't teach at school
right a thousand dollars in two in
nineteen fifty and eight is a 1960 is a
thousand dollars in
2018. the difference is the difference
however is this bought this bought this
product right here
okay and by 2018
it didn't buy the same product it bought
one eighth
one-eighth of the products
okay now what does that mean to you that
means cash
[Music]
right because what happened to these
products these products went up in price
these products went up eight times
while money went down or the pr that
went up and this stayed the same however
you want to figure it out but cash is
not King folks okay cash is not King in
fact you'd have probably been better off
buying a thousand dollars worth of real
estate back in 1960. and getting rid of
your dough
because what do you think that piece of
property would be worth today if it was
in a decent location never loan money to
anyone ever listen to me you're not a
bank you're not an ATM you're not a
credit card okay you got a name it ain't
MasterCard it is I need to make money I
need to take care of family I need to
take care of my business I need to get
my wealth right I need to create wealth
and then and not even then would you
ever loan money to anyone especially
friends and family
okay do not do it I'm telling you don't
solve their money problem all they're
going to do is suck you into their money
problem so number four I have never done
this I've done this one time in in
literally 30 years okay and that time I
was disappointed never loan money to
anyone if they can't get it from a bank
they shouldn't be able to get it from
you their money problems will become
your money problems let them go fix
those if they can and then come back and
I know what you're going to tell me
you're gonna be like oh Grant man it's
all about the money with you that's why
it's called the non-negotiable money
tips this is about money okay I'm
staying away from people that got money
problems if I'm a real friend of yours
and I'm going through trouble right now
why would I want to bring my trouble to
you stay away from people that have
money problems okay these are my
non-negotiable money tips look I came up
from nothing if you don't know who I am
literally started with nothing 25 years
old I had no money no credit no Finance
no Mentor there was no training or
education about money I knew nothing
about it I just knew one thing I wanted
it and I also knew that I wanted more
than I had and so I started studying and
reading every book I could on finance
all these wealthy people I ran into this
book The Millionaire Next Door I'm Gonna
Save my way to money I'm gonna I'm gonna
not drink the coffee and I'm gonna I'm
gonna buy the used truck okay it's
ridiculous okay you guys could get a
million dollars you know less about
money than people that are broke okay a
million dollars is not enough money for
you it's not enough money for your
future it's not enough money for your
security and it's definitely not enough
money for retirement look this these
five days it's 90 minutes a day you guys
carve about 90 minutes for me every day
for five days completely free cost you
nothing
and I promise you I will put you on
track to become a millionaire yeah man
you know so it's not difficult you got
you I can't do the willingness thing you
guys got to sign up for it I can't do
and I know some of some of your audience
are like ah what's the strings attached
what's it uh the strings I want to help
yeah that's the string okay if you've
ever asked for help beg for hell prayed
for Help Wanted help wanted somebody to
take time to help you this is a gift
yeah and it's my gift to you and those
that received the gift it gives me a
gift back to me to fulfill my purpose so
I truly want to help people uh this is
not about inspiration or motivation it's
not about you getting all excited
beating your chat is real tactical dude
it's a strategy it's a specific strategy
yeah and I'd like I've never needed
motivation I don't need anybody to
motivate me I don't need to jump up and
down to get excited I don't I don't need
to do a cold plunge to want to conquer
the world or walk on fire dude I need a
strategy just show me the math yeah and
and show me that and then I'll take it
from there and I'm gonna figure it out
just like you did I highly advise this
stay broke thing
good man because
three Banks this weekend another one
this morning this ain't gonna be over
okay but what happened was we were I
think most of us in a room were taught
hey work hard how many were taught that
yeah bust your ass save your money yeah
the first two parts are right the third
one's wrong you don't want to save your
money you want to get rid of money
convert money
to something else
either another dealership car
dealerships are about real estate
they're not about cars
right you're right or wrong that's it
man the the the the the cars basically
support
owning the real estate that one day in
the future will be worth a lot of money
I've been investing in real estate for
35 years we have 4.1 billion dollars
worth of Real Estate
under control right now 25 000
apartments under management and I truly
believe with what's going on the banks
I'm in Phoenix Arizona today Scottsdale
actually and you see all this beautiful
real estate behind me it's just you know
over the last
50 years real estate has been proven to
be an asset class that when done at the
right time at the right price with the
right debt and the right business plan
real estate has always benefited
from the craziness in the marketplace
you got Banks failing right now or
apparently failing you got money moving
from checking and savings accounts into
the big Banks
and you have office retail apartment
portfolios that are under stress this is
going to be the opportunity of your
lifetime to start investing in real
assets you Bitcoin people out there that
are so interested in real estate I know
you are because you like the cash flow
you like the appreciation
you like the depreciation none of what
you get from Bitcoin certainly you get
possible appreciation but no cash flow
no depreciation
and you don't get those big tax
write-ups to come in real estate because
of what is going on in the marketplace
right now at an Institutional level
this is going to be
if you go back to 2008 9-10 when there
was the mortgage debacle what happened
with real estate is real estate some of
that real estate got cut by 30 and 40
and 50 percent if you would have bought
that real estate in 2010 you would be so
wealthy today
you would be like laughing you'd be like
this is crazy I can't believe it now
remember what happened back then nobody
wanted to touch anything
this is when I made the biggest move of
my lifetime I literally went from 200
units to 12
000 units
I exceeded what I thought I could do
okay because I started figuring out how
to actually put deals together what kind
of real estate will always attract debt
good debt and equity
it's not that I ain't you know increase
the amount of money I had what I had I
increased the amount of understanding I
had about real estate itself about what
kind of real estate Goods good debt even
when the the banks are having problems
what kind of real estate can you buy
today everyone talk about cells and you
are a great you are great with sales but
I think you are a marketing genius I
have to be honest for me you're one of
the greatest marketer right now I'm a
better marketer than I'm a salesperson
oh my goodness and I'm a great
salesperson uh when I and I would rather
be a great better marketer than than a
salesperson why explaining because
because most people don't like sales
okay and and to becoming great sales
person like takes a lot of time and
energy okay and uh almost even a certain
kind of personality which I don't think
most people have
and also even if you become a great
salesperson it's not what you want to
end up being you know great business
people are not great the great business
people you go from a worker then maybe
to a salesperson okay and then a sales
manager and then a CEO of a company or
an executive and then a CEO and then
maybe one day you own the company and
then and then ultimately you don't
multiple companies and run corporations
right that's the evolution well as you
get up here you'll depend on sales but
somebody else is doing them down here
you're dependent on sales to make your
ex that extra hustle so people like look
at this thing I I got to become a great
salesperson but no you want to look over
here you want to start running things it
doesn't have to be your business
but you want to be running sales teams
so
in this Evolution you have to become a
great marketer
to the degree you become a great
marketer anybody can become a great
marketer because you can hide behind the
marketing I don't have to be front or
you don't need to be in front right no
well
it's not that I like it it's just that I
do what I have to do to get to to get
attention on the the offer I didn't
start any social media I didn't have one
follower on social David until 2011. is
that right 2000 yeah I've only been
doing social media marketing for 11
years I'm 64 years old I got introduced
to social media when I was 53 years old
it's not native or easy or or normal or
natural for me when I saw the beauty of
social media was number one it was free
number two I could bang it as much as I
wanted okay like as much as I wanted
they won't stop you no matter how much I
drop on it I can say anything I want and
it's not regulated and it's free this is
perfect for me okay you know everybody
told me to do oh there's a specific time
this is a myth there's a specific time
you should Market you know the time of
day uh number two don't Market too much
number three don't monetize Gary
vaynerchuk became famous for going
monetize I'm like I ain't got a daddy
my daddy don't own a wine shop bro I
gotta monetize okay I need money I got
two kids I have to monetize so I broke
all those rules number one I Market
constantly the best time for me is right
now I add links to almost every post
that I do I've I've raised uh one
billion dollars in cash for Cardone
Capital doing this and I've sold a
billion dollars worth of products over
the internet and nobody really even
knows I exist
also the 15 million people that follow
me and follow whoever follows you is not
as important as the Warriors that won't
follow you that will not like you will
not comment you don't even know they're
watching many of them or watching on
Burner phones the most qualified
audience I have is not my followers it
is the voyeur audience I do have a plan
I always have a plan and everybody
should have a plan and you need to know
exactly what the plan is and you need to
know also that the plan is going to work
okay like I think a lot of people plan
and they cross their fingers most people
have a plan but they really don't know
if it's going to work yes I know my
plans were like I I know this plant I
know what it was I've been through three
or four major recessions okay survived
all of them and I know what I have to do
each time so I've gone back and studied
what does it take to move through this
I've also studied hundreds of years of
cycles of where other families became
wealthy in these Cycles these are
moments and opportunities not problems
it's going to look like a problem to you
there's going to be bad news everywhere
we're in a recession now okay here and
south of here we're in a recession yes
and they're just telling you we're not
but we are and the recession will get
deeper it will be a very long and ugly
nasty recession but there's something
you can do about it so the first thing
is to assess all your situations where
are you with liabilities and assets okay
what's a liability meaning like it's
going to cost you something and what's
assets that you could lean into so you
need to assess those in terms of real
you know my phone's an asset right uh
you know this this is this is a partial
asset that's going to become a liability
because it's going to be an empty cup
here in a second I'm gonna need fuel I'm
need water so
assess those things number two I need to
I need to get rid of the liabilities all
of them including people okay family
members brothers sisters mommies if
their liabilities their liabilities you
do not want to drag these people through
this thing because they're going to drag
you down
when you when you have to carry this
stuff with you you need to move fast in
this cycle okay and then you'll go back
and pick them up later okay okay you
can't everybody's gonna die if you guys
don't do this plan and so I'm going to
leave them for a second so that I can go
get my assets so I can expand and create
wealth for myself so which is the third
step looking back on the year how are
you finding time to do all you do Grant
like what does a typical day look like
for Grant Cardone like how do you
prioritize the big rocks daily well the
number one most important thing today
was your interview
so I'm like we got to do that right and
um you know what really happens for me
in any given day I don't think about
having too much to do ever
uh I don't I'd rather have too much to
do by the way than too little to do I do
a lot better and I'm a lot happier when
I got a lot to do
so be be you know I would just suggest
everybody
don't complain about having too much to
do because if you keep complaining about
it you'll have nothing to do
and I think everybody you know has had
the experience of like a day going by in
a snap of a finger because you had so
much to do as opposed to nothing to do
and it feels like the day never ends
there's another saying about you know if
you want something done find the busiest
person and give them the task because
the person has nothing to do will not
get it done so uh I don't really worry
about too much getting I don't think
about I got too much to do I don't
really think in terms of that but I also
don't do stuff I don't want to do you
know I was driving to the office today I
was late I was doing this interview with
O'Leary and I was a moment late and then
two guys two grown-ups adults are
driving through our Pub a private
parking lot here at the office on
bicycles and I almost hit one of them
and of course you know your response is
when you you hit somebody on a bike on
your property you want to get out and
beat them up first you know and and so
the point of that story is I I made time
for this thing that just showed up on my
radar out of nowhere wasn't on my
schedule and and I made time to be an
idiot for a moment and got emotional so
I don't think it's real that people
don't have time you guys make time for
whatever happens you guys can have
anything you want you got to dream
bigger man you got to do more it's
simple the 2DS dream bigger do more
dream bigger do more dream bigger do
more you don't need to go back to
college
you don't need to go to college
you need to pick one or two people and
let those people Mentor you you probably
need one Mentor that can help you and
the other one is a guide of what not to
do
okay the lighthouse the lighthouse you
know the lighthouse some of you probably
never saw a lighthouse
you know in books you saw a book and
there was a lighthouse in a book
go to the lighthouse
that's a mentor
you don't just need mentors they tell
you what to do you need to pick some
mentors as the Lighthouse of where not
to go
I I have learned more from examples of
what not to do than I have from those
who taught me what to do
see my dad my dad died when he was 52
years old my dad was a great mentor of
mine he taught me how to work hard
I got that work thing down man how many
of you know how to work hard
I can work hard man I can work hard man
I can work hard but my dad couldn't
teach me how to get rich
my dad couldn't teach me how to he
couldn't teach me how to reach 100
million dollars online
without running an ad
using social media
and do it in 100 days and by the way I'm
on track to do that right now
[Music]
okay the next biggest thing I will do in
my life will be crowdfunding for Real
Estate it'll be the biggest thing I've
ever done
that's all about how big can I think
and how much can I do don't try to done
trying to impress anybody
but I do want to inspire people I want
to inspire you
so it's been my mission my mission has
been like if I make it one day I'm going
to show you guys behind the scenes you
get to see my wife
my kids how we conduct ourselves when we
go on trips when I'm on business when
I'm at home I want to show people what
it's like to make it okay I'm not
showing you all the cars and stuff and
the planes and to to like say look at me
look at me look at me I'm saying hey man
nope this is my strategic
literally my my mission a strategic
mission is to show you everyday people
whether you live in in in uh in Africa
or America
Venezuela
or you live in Venice Beach California
okay look there's broke people in both
those places there's hopeful people in
both those places men women kids I don't
care your age your sex your sexual
preferences you're doing drugs not doing
drugs you believe in them or not you're
a republican a Democrat you're a con a
capitalist or a communist
my mission is not political a mission is
to like help people see that
what is possible you want to do
something in life you got to learn the
sales game
I know some of you might be turning this
off right now you're like I don't want
to know anything about sales but before
you turn it off understand this
today I own about 750 million dollars
worth of real estate not all of it looks
like this
uh I've had homes and real estate in
California Arizona
Los Angeles
Austin Texas Alabama
Houston Texas let's see where else found
stuff I own about 5 000 apartments right
now
and I'm going to share something and I'm
going to give you the link below here so
that you can go grab this data
I've written seven books 19 best-selling
audio programs
an online platform that's over 30
million people have used and tested out
on companies that pay me hundreds of
millions of dollars to teach their team
I'm telling you all that to tell you
this
there's one thing
in my entire life that I did to
accomplish everything that I have today
including my wife
and my kids and my free time all that
stuff
started
because I learned how to sell
I learned how to sell I learned how to
do something and by the way that I
didn't like to do I didn't like the
sales game didn't like the rejection you
know wasn't comfortable talking to
people not not really that comfortable
doing this video right now but I'm
willing to why
okay so there's two parts of this one
you got to learn the sales game at some
point I don't care what you do you want
to write a book you want to write a a
movie you want to sell a movie you want
to sell music you want to get people to
pick you up you want to be a celebrity
you want to be a DJ you know a plumber
contractor dentist you got to learn how
to sell period my target my initial
Target in my life has been to work hard
and invest in assets that provide me
with passive income that protect my
Capital provide me with tax write-offs
passive income and mostly to not be in
fear about my money these assets that
we're buying today like this Heights
collection you can't destroy it you
can't get rid of it you can't burn it
down you can't earthquake it you can't
hurricane it it's going to be there
these properties and all the other
properties that I bought look at this we
bought this last year altice mocha
165 million dollar asset
the our bass property in Fort Lauderdale
we're making a big big big bets on Fort
Lauderdale Miami and Houston that deal
was 108 million dollars doing covid we
bought it distress for 98 million
dollars a great deal this property right
here I just closed on this this is in
Boca Raton uh 260. 230 units I wanted
this so bad it was a quick close to
stress sale off Market I wrote a check
for 69 million dollars for that property
if you guys are 35 years old 45 years
old 55 65 even 75 years old
I'm telling you get your money out of
the market quit gambling
okay the ETFs are a gamble listen the
ETFs are a gamble you think they're safe
and they're not the mutual funds are at
risk you think they're safe but I'm
telling you they're not what's safe is
real assets we're coming into probably
what I Believe In Our Lifetime Brian you
and I this will be the biggest recession
of our lifetime you reckon bigger than
and it's it because it's it's an
Institutional level this time it's not a
bunch of people that took mortgages out
on homes that's not where the problem is
the problem this time is with the
biggest players in the world
so what I was saying was like Hey so we
started planning this Eric I think I
talked to you about it back in June and
and here we are now we called it
unbreakable because we want to put
people in their households in a position
where they're unbreakable yes and the
thing about unbreakable is this okay you
cannot be unbreakable without money
this money topic sometimes people skirt
around and they don't talk about it but
um I've become famous and Infamous for
telling people you need more money you
know Brian you've written I don't know
90 books or something right most people
can't do that to get to know an audience
today it's what you had to do 20 years
ago to get an audience today you know we
can do this
yes this is the new book reading of the
21st century for good or for bad yes so
next week we're going to do five
90-minute classes
uh on really getting people to think
about how they can get themselves and
their family in the top one percent for
their honors
what is a mindset or belief that you
have
that you feel most of the time people
disagree with you on
well I think a lot of people think that
I'm a positive person and I'm not okay
this has nothing to do with positivity
or motivation
uh I I'm not I'm not like you know Mr
beat my chest I'm excited and I'm gonna
I'm gonna see myself through this
because I'm gonna will myself through it
no I'm not going to do that like I'm
going to do something
what I'm going to do is do something I'm
going to make a call I'm going to send
out an email I'm going to follow that up
I'm going to build a team that can do
the same thing like I'm going to win on
action and it doesn't mean it's it
doesn't mean I'm gonna outwork you
I'm going to out result you
so and I'm not trying to out result you
by the way I'm just like I need to I
need to get results in the marketplace
so I remember uh Gary vaynerchuk was in
my studio once and he was telling me
he's like I'll outwork you I'm like bro
you I mean we just met it you don't know
me I don't know you I don't know what
your work ethic is I don't know what you
do and there's no way you can know
whether you outwork me or not and by the
way it doesn't even matter
what matters is do we get results
and so
what we've been successful with this
whole 10x thing is about hey I am going
to set a Target
10 times higher than what I need for
myself and I'm going to do whatever I
have to do between now and the
attainment of that Target to to get that
that is not a mindset it is a decision
but it's not some positivity thing or
enthusiasm like I think people mistake
that I think that's that's to answer
your question I'm talking to an audience
that wants to get rich just trying to
really like make something make
something big yeah like become like
Robert Smith Rich you know he he's the
wealthiest black man in America or Don
peoples my friend who's worth a couple
billion dollars in playing in the real
estate game or you know like I I want to
get to the top of the food chain where I
get to start making rules he who has the
goal makes the rule and so I don't want
a little money I don't want a retirement
account I don't want my house paid for I
don't care about any of that stuff I
want to get rich I want to create
tremendous amounts of wealth for for the
people that that my community for the
people it started off for my handful
right me my wife my kids and then once
I'm like okay I can help more than that
I can help I can
I don't mean my neighborhood
people in my neighborhood can be helped
right okay they can be helped they need
help by the way where I live right down
the street they just don't know they
need help they're rich but they're not
wealthy they're not helping anybody else
dude they're just helping themselves
it's freaking terrible it's a it's a
life of poverty to have your house paid
for it's a mental poverty like oh I got
my house paid for I got my two cars my
kids are going to private schools and
I'm miserable because there's no purpose
uh like I'm helping millions of people
around the world I've created leverage
on my Leverage
you leverage your leverage like 15
000 times it's unbelievable
yeah I like like in 12 years I didn't
know I could do this right it was
because people started believing in me
man one and and then and then when I
started seeing other people do this when
it became real to me
you know that
you know when I saw oh wow what was I
thinking
what was I thinking I'll tell you one of
the biggest culprits
one of the biggest thieves in our
society and one of the biggest mistakes
I made in my career was like simply just
not being around the right people
I was around people that loved me when I
should have been around people that had
done something
you know
oh man I love her so much I love this
book but they hadn't done anything
like like guys you know you can love you
you know
you need to get around some people that
have done something so you can take care
of the ones you love
because if you're not around people that
have done something you can't really you
can only do to the degree that you're
around winners I'm sorry your golf games
not going to get better playing around
guys that don't know how to play golf
hey you guys keep asking me what enough
money is how many times I got to tell
you first of all if you're asking a
question you don't have enough money
number two enough money by definition at
least my definition would be you can
take care of everyone you love everyone
all the people your sister that you
forgot about your aunt that took care of
you when you were growing up maybe a
school teacher that helped you out a
bunch is struggling now but you can help
your two kids your wife or husband
and your parents and beyond that you
know what I'm saying you can reach deep
start helping all the people you love
that would be enough money and still
take care of yourself by the way I know
some of you out there taking care of
everybody else but you don't take care
of yourself so you'd have to be able to
take care of everybody you love all the
people you forgot that you love and the
people that can't take care of
themselves the guy on the street corner
that you're like dude I feel sorry for
this guy I want to help him out you can
take care of all those people and
yourself and I'm not done
okay
when you expire and you're done your
history you can't work anymore can't
produce anymore you're you're expired
you would steal you got enough money to
still take care of the people you love
the things you love the Charities you
love the causes that you believe in yeah
that's what would be enough money
and still not be out by the way
you would have abundance in every way
you would have Wealth Beyond anything
that's destructible
it would last forever and you could
literally change the world
with the money that you produce because
you were committed
you were charitable you cared enough to
go big enough
you guys man y'all just don't care about
enough people that's why you think so
small
[Music]
it's not about the cars and the shades
and the clothes and the watches yeah all
those things are cool and everything but
the real game
is can you create enough wealth
to continue
and you can by the way I mean it's
possible for anyone to do if you dream
big enough it's not possible if you
don't make this big
but if you did think this big
you could think this big if you got
around other people that thought this
big
they'd encourage you to think big and
really live into your full potential
[Music]
to create create you could absolutely
100 starting from zero still create
enough wealth to take care of you all
the people you love all the people you
forgot that you love and even when
you're done you can keep taking care of
people you guys want to take some notes
right now I'm going to teach you the
money game and you're gonna have to
learn the money again okay I'm gonna
show you how to get money
because on this planet you have to know
how to manage money one of the most
important lessons you're going to learn
in your life right now you don't want to
add you want to multiply this is how you
get money all right one you get it now I
need to keep it okay I didn't write save
it what you want to do is you want to
multiply it what's your name
King King I like that man okay so look
King uh if when you come back here when
you come back here let's see what's the
date today 28 thank you man man you're
on your game too huh he says I get 100
for that sure man what's your name thank
you Vincent my I had an uncle named
Vincent good guy he always believed in
me
and you this guy this guy this guy huh
this guy's a Storyteller right here huh
I like that you got some moose bro go
ahead there you go Vincent first part of
this little game right here is you don't
need to make something to get money but
you do need to get in the right room
with the right people that have money if
I didn't have any money could I play
this game with you guys no if I was
broke if I was doing the wrong stuff if
I was out you know drinking and drugging
on the weekends I and I'm losing stuff
and I'm going crazy and um then I can't
help you how should people be framing
their mindset everyone out of anything
in the middle man you don't want to be
baloney on the baloney sandwich the
bologna is what gets eaten like you
don't you want to get outside the
sandwich you don't want to be crammed in
you know you want to figure out what
does the top of this pyramid structure
do
you know how do you get at the top for
your family the best health you can get
in the best intelligence the best
connections how do you have friends and
family that are all have enough money
and mobility and time to go do the
things you want to go do with them
that's what these people do
these people want to spend 100 on a
ticket and spend three or four days you
know hobnobbing with one another and
staying at the Beverly Hills Hotel where
the hotel rooms are 2 200 bucks a night
and eating 40 french fries if they want
to do that with themselves they've got
themselves in a position to operate up
there with those people
and so that's the big thing it's not
send my kids to college and pay off my
mortgage since I was 13 years old I have
been trying to find my way I've been
trying to find my way to this word right
here to my dreams how do I make my
dreams a reality so like every day like
I know this what I pay attention to I
end up getting you guys ever done that
before where you're like you're riding a
bike or something and you're like I
don't want to hit that whole I don't
want to hit that crack I don't want to
hit that crack I don't want to take rack
I don't want that rock I don't want to
hit that thing I don't hit that thing
the next thing what bang you fall down
you hit the thing one thing I do every
day and I'm telling you a little trick
in life if you pay attention to
something enough whether it's good or
bad it's going to become a reality so
when I wake up in the morning what I do
every day rather than just ending up
with some life whatever the leftovers
are whatever whatever you get I don't
want to just like get what I get I want
to get what I want how many of you want
to get what you want
okay so when I was 10 years old I lost
my dad my dad passed away when I was 10
years old and it left me with my mom my
twin brother my older brother and two
sisters I was the youngest of five there
was seven of us in a small house and the
other thing that was in our house was
one other thing maybe you guys know what
this thing is I tell you what I'll pay a
hundred dollars if you know the other
person that lived at our house
it's a four-letter word boom that's
right give this man the hundred dollars
give this man a hundred dollars right
here
okay okay the school that pays every day
so check it out so check it out so fear
have you guys ever experienced fear in
your house
ma'am I was in fear all the every day
and and the fear made me sad because I
could see my mom was scared I didn't
know enough to be scared I could just
tell from my mom my mom was scared
because my dad had passed and she didn't
know how she was going to take care of
the family
and at that moment one of my dreams or
goals
I really like the word goals better than
dreams
one of my goals became hey I don't want
to live in fear every day
I don't want to have fear every day I
want to have freedom
from Fear because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for some incredible garyvee
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there lean in dramatically more to
things that are positive your
grandfather podcasts lean into
positivity then eyes wide open and is
this delusional and lacks practicality
like you know if I just